[Music]
somehow he always manages to generate
suspense even for a moment so widely
anticipated
so it was to an Anthem of Revolution and
into a sea of his most loyal supporters
the former president delivered his pitch
to be the next one in order to make
America great and glorious again I am
tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
for over an hour he spoke framing his
achievements alongside Biden's
challenges China Russia Iran and North
Korea were in check
and respected they respected the United
States and quite honestly they respected
me it was familiar stuff scripted but it
felt flat lacking the energy of his
rallies he dismissed the many legal
cases against him I'm a victim I will
tell you and the fact that his
candidates were so often not the chosen
ones in last week's midterms well that's
fake news he said we love Trump outside
here's why he thinks he is the future
make America great again the foot
soldiers of the trumpism movement only
the most loyal here of course yet this
does stretch across the country and it
cuts into society
but beyond that moment beyond the focus
here is Donald Trump really the future
too the Republican Party establishment
has tried so many times to cut Trump
loose after the January the sixth
Insurrection and many trumpian moments
in between the search for someone
different for someone safer has
continued but every time they are drawn
back to Trump's brand and Trump's base
now the Republican Challengers will
Circle a home turf battle beckons Dawn
versus Ron
the Santa's re-elected Florida Governor
by a landslide last week it was the the
greatest uh Republican victory in the
history of the State of Florida he is
trumpian but he's not Trump
yeah baby it's Trump time for now this
Remains the force behind Trump
redirecting this energy switching their
loyalty that is the challenge
[Music]
Mark Stone Sky News in Florida